j'étais chez moi à 5 heures du matin sur
facebook mon collègue ou lee james qui
m'envoie un message sur messenger qui me
dit là il ya un combat demain en
république tchèque tu veux boxer on
prend l'avion dans deux heures zhao
salut brut c'est sami sanaa je suis cinq
fois champion du monde de kick boxing
boxe thaï j'ai plus de 150 combat mon
actif j'ai été élu trois fois meilleur
boxeur de l'année
là on est dans mon quartier d'enfance le
noyau et je vais vous raconter mon
histoire
j'ai vécu ici avec ma famille c'est là
où mon père mes oncles mes grands
parents ont été depuis le début c'est là
où j'ai commencé à errer un petit peu tu
vois où j'ai commencé à faire mes
petites conneries les 400 coups je vais
aller en prison très jeune j'avais un
ami à moi et qui s'appelle lance eau qui
était déjà dans un inscrit dans un club
de boxe thaï dans le xviie et vu qu'ils
connaissaient mon caractère et mon
comportement il m'a proposé d'aller
faire un entraînement avec lui et je me
rappelle que la veille la veille que
j'aille à ce premier entraînement on
était très jeune on avait 13 14 ans on
s'était battu à porte de saint cloud
avec des skinheads à l'époque c'était
une très grosse vague avec des coups de
chaises et en sortant de ça je me suis
dit il faut vraiment que je trouve que
je trouve un quelque chose pour me
calmer et quelque chose pour qu'ils
puissent me canaliser et
j'ai fui direct le lendemain à
l'entraînement ça faisait un mois que
j'étais inscrit dans le club et j'ai
fait directement mon premier combat
alors que généralement ça prend du temps
[Musique]
car au premier vol direct donc là à
partir de ce moment là j'ai vu que
c'était fait pour moi quoi je me voyais
déjà être un grand champion donc j'avais
un objectif dans la tête qu'il ne
fallait pas que je lâche donc je pense
que ça m'a sauvé le moment le plus dur
de ma carrière c'est vraiment quand
quand croyaient pas en moi ne voulait
pas trop trop que je boxe dans l'est
dans les gros gala ou à l'étranger donc
ce que je faisais que moi j'avais une
technique jallet sur les réseaux sociaux
sur facebook à l'époque et que
j'allais voir les promoteurs et je leur
envoyais des messages rémois boxer même
gratuitement je boxe je vais battre
tonga je vais lui faire du sale je vais
le mettre ko vraiment pour attirer
l'attention et que le promoteur se dit
là on a quelqu'un on a quelqu'un de hors
norme avant les risques c'était la rue
est pris aussi beaucoup professionnalisé
pour faire ça mieux donc vers conditions
j'ai pas du tout une carrière comme les
autres déjà j'ai jamais été dans le
circuit fédéral j'étais vraiment livré à
moi-même c'était vraiment moi et moi moi
mon club moi mon entraîneur
[Applaudissements]
la qualité première je pense que c'est
le mental et le coeur que sur le ring ou
dans la cage un très très grand coeur ça
veut dire que je lâche pas du début
jusqu'à la fin et je déteste qu'on
touche je déteste qu'on me mettre des
coups j'aime pas recevoir de coups en
fait donc dès que je reçois un coup ça
me transcende et là j'ai envie de
remettre la mise fois mille et
mentalement je me transforme comme dans
dragon ball z tu vois je me transforme
et là je veux
je veux tombale quoi
sur youtube
c'est
quelqu'un qui vient qui paye un billet
pour voir un combat je sais qu'il veut
un gros combat je sais qu'il veut du feu
je sais qu'il veut du show et je veux
qu'ils rentrent chez lui et qu'il en ait
eu plein la vue et qu'il existe un site
c'était trop bien tu vois donc en fait
je boxe pas que pour moi je me moque
vraiment pour tout le monde
et début on l'a eu mauvaise appréhension
le mois du peut-être un bon physique a
comme on le voit sur le ring dans la
cage mais en réalité en dehors du ring
et de la cage je suis tout l'opposé
c'est à dire que je quelqu'un de discret
deux de réserve et je suis quelqu'un qui
jetterait dans l'assaut je fais
énormément de séminaires de master class
justement pour être auprès des jeunes
leur transmettre un peu ma philosophie
de la boxe mais technique moi ma
carrière va se finir un jour donc il
faut il faut la relève et pour qu'on
soit vraiment performant au long terme
pour apprendre nouveau faut tout donner
au nouveau il faut être là pour eux
tellement j'étais solo tout ça eh ben
j'ai pas envie que ça se reproduise
j'ai pas envie que des petits jeunes se
retrouvent tous seuls livrés à eux-mêmes
à être frustrés à se dire pourquoi si
pourquoi ça pourquoi ci et là je vous
ouvre une structure justement où je
pourrai accueillir tous ceux qui ont
envie de te faire de la boxe qui ont
envie de juste faire de la boxe pour le
plaisir se défouler en tout cas je serai
là
[Musique]